conseil de défense sanitaire a été
l'occasion pour l'exécutif de faire le
point sur la situation en ile de france
alors que les hôpitaux sont saturés et
sous tension et que l'île de france a
dépassé les 400 cas pour 100000
habitants un taux d'incidence qui a
augmenté de 20% ces derniers jours et
puis sans compter l'apparition dû varier
en breton qui va peut-être changer la
donne en tout cas d'après gabriel atta
le porte parole du gouvernement il va
bien la voir de nouvelles mesures
annoncées dès demain pour ce week end
alors confinement ou pas là est la
question on en sera un peu plus dès
demain lors de cette traditionnelle
conférence de presse donnée par jean
castex et olivier ferrand
je vous propose d'écouter gabriela
talent était décidé ce matin en conseil
de défense que des mesures
supplémentaires seraient prises dans un
certain nombre de territoires dans les
prochaines heures
des concertations seront emmenés par
l'état avec les élus locaux dans les
régions île de france et au de france et
dans les départements qui sont contigus
à ces régions pour partager l'état de la
situation actuelle pour recueillir
l'avis des élus locaux sur les
différentes mesures qui sont envisagées
le premier ministre réunira par ailleurs
cet après-midi les comités de liaison
parlementaire à l'issue de ce travail
le premier ministre avec le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé alan seront à
demain à 18 heures dans une conférence
de presse
les mesures qui seront retenus pour ces
territoires pour une application à
partir de ce week-end mais la situation
et continue de se dégrader d'après
gabriel attal ces derniers jours elle
l'exécutif n'a pas été très rassurant
jean castex a même évoqué la possibilité
d'une troisième vague
le premier ministre ne s'en est pas
caché la situation elle est préoccupante
et à vrai dire elle l'est depuis
plusieurs jours
alors si le gouvernement a tenté de
retarder l'échéance l'hypothèse d'un
confinement s'affirme de plus en plus
emmanuel macron de son côté avait déjà
prévenu est dès lundi il faudra
appliquer des restrictions adaptée et
proportionnée en tout cas le
gouvernement s'est fixé un objectif
ambitieux 30 millions de personnes
devraient être vaccinés et
6 juin si tout fonctionne bien